مرحبا بكم مشاهدينا في مجزيلنباء نقلت
رويترز عن مستشار برئاسه الاوكرانيه قوله
ان محادثات تجري مع الشركائها جانب لتوريد
صواريخ بعيده المدى وطائرات هجوميه لذلك
بعد اعلان واشنطن تقديم حزمه مساعدات
امنيه جديده لكييف بقيمه مليارين و200
مليون دولار تتضمن صواريخ طويله المدى
للمره الاولى
هذا وقال الرئيس الروسي ان المهمه
الاساسيه امام موسكو هي وقفو وردع اي
محاولات قصف من اوكرانيا للاراضي الروسيه
المتاخمه لها حسب تعبيرا اضاف بوتين
اجتماع بشانه السبل اعاده اعمار البنيه
التحتيه في الاراضي الروسيه المتاخمه
لاوكرانيا ان الحكومه الروسيه توصلت الى
حلول لدعم تلك المناطق
في تونس استنكر اتحاد الشغل توقيفه احد
نقبيين ودعا الى التعبئه للدفاع عن الحريه
العامه والحق في الاضراب مجربي اتهم
القيادي وفي جبهه الخلاص الوطنيه لرضا
بالحاج في تصريح الجزيره الرئيس قيس سعيد
الخلطي بين مهامه كرئيس جمهوريه وبينما
سماهم ميوله السياسيه الشخصيه وعداواته
وروحه الانتقاميه ازاء معرضه
بدورها قالت لمياء لخميري عضو الهيئه
التنفيذيه لجبهه الخلاص الوطني المعارضه
في مقابله مع الجزيره ان خطاب الرئيس
التونسي كانت تخويفيا لخصوم الرئيس
السياسيين والنقابيين على حد سواء
قال نائب المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه ان انخفاض نسبه المشاركه في
الانتخابات التونسيه مؤشر على ضروره
انخراط الحكومه في عمليه شامله لتوسيع
المشاركه السياسيه اضاف بتيل ان واشنطن
ستواصل دعم تطلعات الشعب التونسي الى
حكومه ديمقراطيه
شهدت انجلترا وويلز اضرابات عماليه هي
الاكبر منذ 10 سنوات شارك فيها نصف مليون
شخص ينتمون الى نقابات معلمين مدارس
وسائقي القطارات والحافلات وحراس الامن
والمحاضرين الجامعيين وموظفي الخدمه
المدنيه وذلك للاحتجاج على تدني الاجور
وهذه المطالبه برفع الرواتب في ظل موجه
الغلاء بينما بدات الحكومه الثابته في
موقفها برفض مطالب النقابات ودعت المعارضه
الى ادانه الاضرابات مشدده على ان رفع
الاجور سيؤدي الى زياده التضخم
في مكتشفوا اختتمت اعماله وقمه رباعيه قمه
الرباعيه ضمت قاده الصومال وجيبوتي وكينيا
واثيوبيا وناقشه القمه الوضع الامني في
الصومال وتنسيق الجهود لمواجهه حركه
الشباب
[موسيقى]